another item of adversity that the
chiefs have to deal with as they enter
the slow time between the end of the
off-season program and training camp
this frank clark arrest
second time since march on gun related
charges and most recently
he's got an uzi and a duffel bag that's
open i mean first of all if you if you
feel compelled to have an uzi which is a
clearly illegal weapon but if for
whatever reason you feel compelled to
have an uzi and it's in a duffel bag
just zip it shut so you don't see it
when they look it i mean that's a simple
that's a simple tip you don't have it in
plain view so the cop oh there's an uzi
an uzi is a highly illegal weapon a
weapon of mass destruction you pull that
trigger and 50 people are dead
what who the hell needs an uzi chris i i
have no idea mike it makes no no sense
to me at all it doesn't you know i mean
there's a guy that has a little bit of a
checkered pass certainly but man he's a
good football player you know he does a
lot of good things for their football
team is he a superstar pass rusher in my
opinion no
but
like a guy that you go is that next
level down from a superstar does
everything pretty well and i to me those
are the things i just don't understand i
don't for a player like frank clark you
kind of got you know
you got everything you want
right in your hand and there he is you
know taking a risk with having that in
the car why i don't know where are you
going with that listen i'm not trying to
understand anybody's life but a uzi like
you said like what are we were we going
to get in like a major gunfight in the
neighborhood i don't know it just seems
a little much for me
and guys get arrested on gun charges all
the time we see guilty pleas we see
reduced charges we see slaps on the
wrist for the most part but this to me
has
a much graver feel to it because it is
an uzi you typically only see oozies in
the movies yeah you don't see somebody
walking around with an uzi it is a
felony
and he may be looking at jail time for
this you get a prosecutor that wants to
send a message to the world that
that uh you know you get caught with an
uzi you're going to do hard time
remember what happened to plexigo burst
he shot himself in the leg with a normal
gun right and what happened the only
person he shot was himself and he went
to jail for two years because of the gun
laws in new york an uzi's illegal
everywhere
and you know this is what people think
that that those who have fame and
notoriety get a pass when they find
themselves in the gears of the criminal
justice system oftentimes prosecutors
prosecutors say hey this is this is a
way to send the loudest message
as a see to shining c about what
behavior is accepted we're going to
throw the book at this celebrity because
the trial is going to get covered and
the sentence is going to get covered and
everybody's going to know
don't mess around even though we don't
have the resources to catch everybody
who
messes around this way we want to scare
people into not doing it and a high
profile prosecution like this will do it
you know the league's got personal
conduct policy or weapons policy and it
just feels to me
like a bigger deal
than
anytime you know there was a
the defensive back from the saints he
got arrested in cleveland
the guy who's on the yeah marshawn
lattimore the guy in his his option here
you know yeah that had a different feel
to it you know it's a
the the because it was just a gun and
was it registered was it stolen whatever
this is an uzi
this is an uzi this is a big deal
like like wonder what well i just wonder
like if he wasn't frank clark and had
like you know
they traded for him has a huge salary
has a huge number that counts against
the salary cap this year the play hasn't
been what they want it to be i mean they
didn't get frank clark and pay him all
this money to get six sacks that's what
he got last year they didn't do that
like to me you know i i look at it and i
just wonder with some of the stuff
they're they're under the microscope
because of the read thing and all of
that to where i hear you it does seem a
little serious and all that but i just
i don't think anybody's gonna anything's
gonna be done to the player at least
through the kansas city chiefs like i i
would say like he'd be in danger getting
cut if he didn't have such a big dead
dead money and and such a big you know
chunk of the salary cap this year i i
would say that but but because of the
situation in this contract i don't think
that's the case
yeah there i'm doing the math here real
quick he's up near 20 million dollars if
they would cut him right and he's got
18.5 million based salary this year
that's guaranteed for skill injury and
cap they could try to find a way around
that they could try to
invalidate and void the guarantee but
um i i you know
i think they probably just go forward
yeah and uh wait and see what the legal
system does wait and see what the league
does because financially their hands are
tied here and this is the deal they did
when they made that trade and they
signed with that long term contract he
had that issue in college that ended up
being a problem uh and and it created a
ton of controversy seahawks if you
remember that when i was a second round
pick yeah so they knew what they they
knew look i i can't say that they
they reasonably should have foreseen
he'd get arrested with an uzi but they
knew
when they traded for him that this is a
guy who had some off-field stuff yeah
that could rear its ugly head at some
point in the future they they can't say
they didn't know that no they well
they've been a team that's been willing
to take those chances that that's that
is part of what kansas city is they've
taken chances on guys who yeah have a
little bit of a checkered past and yeah
this guy he's no boy scout that's
certainly you know the case here and
yeah they're they're kind of eating it
on this one at this point right now so
we'll see but i mean i mean you said it
like the legal system
guns in your car twice and uzi
like
i don't i have a hard time thinking the
nfl doesn't do something here right i
mean would you think that there's gonna
be a suspension at some point
i i assume there will be the question is
how long do they wait for the legal
system and how much do they do
on their own and does this rise to the
level of maybe even paid leave we've
talked about it so much with the sean
watson has become an issue for frank
clark we'll see how that plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports